io sono un architetto da qualche anno
faccio l'architettura è un modo diverso
lavoro con le pubbliche amministrazioni
con i gruppi informali con le
organizzazioni con chi deve decidere e
decide di cedere potere di decisione
alle persone per sbagliare meno perché
oggi le politiche sono complicate quindi
occorre coinvolgere le persone che sono
beneficiari delle politiche e allora ho
fatto del mio lavoro un operazione di
ascolto perché l'ascolto il senso lavoro
con degli strumenti molto semplici quasi
da da scuola i pennarelli i fogli fogli
mobili e questi fogli raccolgono le i
pensieri delle persone spesso li
manipoliamo insieme al gruppo per
costruire tanti pezzetti di terra che
sono in qualche modo il senso di
quell'incontro ma se la terra è fatta
tutta a pezzetti il cielo è uno solo e
allora l'idea è costruire questo questa
specie di ascesa dalla terra al cielo
come pioggia che cade dalla terra al
cielo e creare delle macchine delle
infografiche che raccolgano i contributi
di tutti e quindi con nuovi strumenti
digitali poi si riportano quelle
esperienze dentro un panorama condiviso
certe volte questi panorami sono interi
libri intere norme inter i discorsi
lineari complessi che si devono portare
alle persone perché le personali possano
elaborare e allora in quel caso uso una
piccola strategia ricordare che pagina
paese paesaggio hanno la stessa
etimologia sono i pagus sono il luogo in
cui troviamo il senso e confidiamo come
dire la nostra storia la rappresentiamo
e allora interi libri vengono
trasformati in immagini che possono
essere in qualche modo possono orientare
su grande formato le persone
però queste sono interpretazioni che non
si possono fare in tempo reale bisogna
elaborarle quasi un'operazione della
camera certe volte i discorsi non li sai
avvengono improvvisamente in un luogo
comune in cui si decide
e ci si ascolta e prima di decidere il
passaggio verso il cielo è fondamentale
e allora il paesaggio che raccoglie
questo paesaggio questo passaggio verso
il cielo deve essere una fusione
favorevole o inventato questa storia del
muro nomade immaginando una cosa molto
semplice una superficie quasi non finita
un rotolo di carta per fare
un'operazione molto semplice una specie
di cantastorie al contrario io non
conosco mai la storia che avvengono solo
le persone che me le raccontano le
ascolto e scrivo scrivo come fatto
fluido e raccolgo come in una visione
favorevole il loro discorso questa cosa
l'ho fatta per un po di tempo una volta
una di quelle volte sono arrivato in un
posto assolutamente straordinario che il
museo della mente all'ex manicomio santa
maria della pietà a roma c'è un
padiglione che è stato trasformato
configurato con un luogo della memoria
luogo del dolore ma anche della delle
capacità mentali delle persone da studio
azzurro e lì c'era un workshop che
parlava di innovazione quindi li ho
scritto quello che le persone dicevano
poi dopo ho visitato lo spazio del muro
del museo ho trovato questa cosa qua è
una riproduzione su plexiglass molto
lunga di un graffito di un pezzo molto
piccolo di un graffito dean of fernando
resto i nanetti era un uomo che era
stato rinchiuso per oltraggio a pubblico
ufficiale nel manicomi volterra e la
cciaa rimasto per anni ea graffitato le
sue storie immaginaria i suoi pensieri i
suoi paesaggi mentali sul muro del
reparto immaginate un muro di 180 metri
di lunghezza alto 2 che è stato scavato
dalla sua fibbia e lui si definiva un
astronautico ingegnere minerario quando
del sistema mentale e quando ho visto
quella cosa sono rimasto fulminato
perché ho capito che i muri che stavo
facendo
sono nomadi perché hanno bisogno di
portare la libertà delle persone la
libertà dei discorsi dentro un paesaggio
comune in giro per il mondo quando se
fosse uno scavo come se per andare verso
il cielo
voi dovete scavare giù nella terra e il
fondo ritrovare la luce al di là degli
antipodi
e questa storia qua in quella sera si è
trasformata in una specie di museo
mentale condiviso perché guarda caso
abbiamo usato molti colori diversi
perché le voci avevano colori diversi
bene questa storia è continuata e la
porta ancora insieme fatto una piccola
sperimentazione per voi ma è la cosa più
interessante è che un flusso è quasi una
su una tempesta un flusso consapevole e
a che fare con una cosa che mentre
accade parla di una parola che non è
traducibile in italiano e in inglese ma
è molto nota ai pugliesi che si chiama
picio il pri cioè la felicità di fare
una cosa non c'è nessun motivo per cui
la fai se non quello di farla e quando
la fai sei contento come la notte di
natale e soprattutto e quando le altre
persone che ti vedono che sei presa
questa cosa si bruciano e questa cosa
qua io ho ricollegato all'infanzia
perché quando ero piccolino giocavo con
mio cugino io sono sono come lui non ho
fratelli o sorelle e lui quando si
implicava faceva lo si faceva questa
cosa qua che non so se reggono i
microfoni ma è sostanzialmente la
felicità di fare di entrare dentro
questa tempesta questa consapevolezza in
cui avviene un passaggio di stato sono
le nuvole che si si annodano insieme e
che reano senso ai nostri discorsi
quindi l'ascolto e consolidamento di
queste parole e consolidamento anche
della felicità perché le persone sono la
felicità sono il senso della felicità
quando hanno accanto persone
significativa e questo un aggregato di
discorsi significativi dove tu catturi
le nuvole gli dà un senso perché con i
colori poi tradurre dai toni dei
discorsi la priorità di alcune parole
rispetto ad un altro ma un caos un magma
in cui tu accetti di entrarci dentro e
tu crei delle come vive delle immagini
che sono la persona crea le io le seguo
soltanto non ho nessuna responsabilità
nessun merito in questo ma tutto diventa
una foresta pluviale e lì sopra vedete
prima un discorso fatto da più relatori
in una sala su un museo sensibile poi è
iniziata la tempesta è iniziato un brain
storming ha cominciato a piovere vedete
gli spazi sotto sono le parole che
piovono è un po l'idea di calvino che la
felicità e la fantasia un posto dove ci
piove dentro e questo spazio classico e
così sono i discorsi non hanno più il
nome delle persone hanno il senso della
fusione di tutte le i punti di vista
perché spesso le persone quando parlano
non hanno soltanto interesse a
raccontare un'idea un concetto sono
interessati sostanzialmente a definirle
nei dettagli di quel discorso
e allora io provo a fare delle polaroid
dei discorsi per raccontare tutto questo
così come loro immaginano che sia
possibile raccontare e costruisco queste
sole pagine fuori scala molto grandi
dove tu puoi navigare non trovi il tuo
nome ma alla fine diventa una specie di
quarta parete comune fra le persone e te
che scrivi e fra le persone che parlano
si crea questa membrana in cui tutti i
discorsi poi sono luogo di esplorazione
possono diventare tavoli tavoli i nomadi
che vanno dappertutto e diventa una
specie di villaggio artigiano dove tutti
cominciano a scrivere a prendere
dappertutto perché solo dilagando tu
trovi il senso e l'apprendimento e
ovunque in ogni in ogni parte dei
discorsi e diventa una tela spesso si
srotola terra questa storia perché le
persone che narrano poi cominciano a
leggersi ed è questa pratica che più
interessante spesso questi luoghi di
scrittura raccolgono punti vista molto
diversi fra di loro anche molto in
conflitto però accade che dopo alla fine
quando finisce un discorso ognuno va a
cercare la sua parte il suo pezzo
discorso e vedere cosa avrò detto che
cosa è stato esattamente riportato in
quel momento legge anche gli altri e si
legge dentro
gli altri queste mappe in qualche modo
diventare un modo per ricucire il nostro
rapporto con le persone ci stanno
accanto e per diventare insieme una
specifica unità di autori i nomadi che
accettano di camminare perché il fondo
la bellezza non esiste se non esistono
se le persone non ci camminano dentro e
la bellezza non è fatta come dire di
immagini perfette ma di avventure umane
da piedi scalzi per cui tu cammini e
solchi mari dove la scrittura può essere
una rappresentazione delle persone che
sono quasi specchi d'acqua alcuni noi
sono superfici ma alcune di noi nei
discorsi trovano la profondità
dell'ascolto e dei luoghi delle persone
pur che noi ci ricordiamo sempre una
cosa che non è fondamentale la come dire
la la forma della scrittura
ma sono fondamentali delle persone che
le hanno generate e per cui il senso è
purché tu sappia che la superficie del
mare non è il mare una bellissima poesia
di silvano agosti che lui ha scritto
immaginando probabilmente quella che chi
sia per tutti noi vorremmo arrivare io
di là un po ho provato a raccontare
delle nuvole qua ce n'è una un pezzetto
di nuvola che sta sta cominciando a
vagare verso di voi ma è solo un
frammento perché il bello della storia
deve ancora venire
grazie